Republican Senator Mitt Romney was confronted
yesterday in an airport.
It looks like DCA in Washington, DC.
From the video that we are going to play,
you all know, I didn't vote for Mitt Romney
in 2012.
I voted for Barack Obama.
You all know Mitt Romney is a conservative
Republican, completely not in line with my
politics, but Mitt Romney in this particular
confrontation.
With a complete and utter loon sounds eminently
reasonable and completely respectful and polite,
even when he really has no reason to be given
how he's being treated in this video, you
are going to see the end result of the heat
Romney has been taking from the right, from
the pro Trump.
Right.
Because while Mitt Romney is a right wing
religious Republican, he has refused to indulge
Donald Trump in some of his authoritarian
insanity.
Mitt Romney didn't vote for Trump in the presidential
election.
Mitt Romney on one of two impeachment counts,
actually did vote to convict Mitt Romney in
the Senate.
And in this video, Mitt Romney is accosted
in the airport and he's way more polite than
many people would have been to this woman.
When Mitt Romney is the calming voice of reason
in a conversation, you know, things are crazy
and that they are with this Magga cult that
is here and is likely going to be with us
for some period of time.
So let's look at the video.
We joined the video with Mitt Romney sitting
by himself at the airport with his mask on
as required, approached by a masked person.
We might call her a Maskell's Holy Karen if
we wanted some kind of name.
Let's join the video.
How are you doing?
Don't tell me what to do.
Please put your mask on as it's required by
law.
I'm standing six feet away.
I'm sorry.
It's OK, I tell you, because you know what?
I'm going to go out and do it because I want
to have a chat with you.
So first of all, I don't need a mask because
I'm six feet away.
You're in the airport.
The airport airports require masks, lady.
And that's just a microcosm of how they make
up the rules as they as they go along, as
they want them to be.
Let's continue.
Why aren't you supporting President Trump?
You support President Trump.
Agree with you're not supporting him.
I'm sorry.
I do agree with this for and I support those
things.
Are you going to support him in the fraudulent
votes this election, though?
And why not?
Because as you might imagine, this is going
to be a real one.
I'm sorry, can you say that again?
It's a long story, but we have a constitution.
The constitutional process is clear.
I'll follow the Constitution explaining that
we made a decision.
So Mitt Romney is asked, why won't he support
Trump trying to steal the election?
And Romney says, because we have a constitution.
And you would think that these constitutional
fetishists, if they were actually committed
to constitutionality, would respect that in
Mitt Romney.
But, no, it actually makes her more angry.
And this is one of my favorite moments.
Well, you haven't supported him and you didn't
even support him in the election.
No, I didn't.
Why?
For reasons like.
You were voted in as a conservative to represent
the conservative constituents, period.
That's not how the Constitution works.
Now, that's fascinating for a few reasons.
She says you were voted in as a conservative
Republican to represent conservatives.
And there's two things there.
First, as Mitt points out, he's elected to
represent his entire constituency and to defend
the Constitution.
Stealing an election that Trump lost is not
constitutional.
But there's also this idea that even a conservative
Republican like Mitt Romney isn't really conservative
unless he's trying to steal the election for
Trump, when in reality there's nothing conservative
about trying to execute an unconstitutional
coup when Trump lost the election.
Let's watch more.
It is your voted in to represent us.
You work for us.
Am I wrong?
I work for the people of Utah.
Exactly.
And I am from Utah, which is why I voted.
I know there's a lot of people that didn't
vote for you.
And we'll make sure that when people hear
this, you admit it, you know it.
You know it's me.
They didn't want you in there anyway.
So to be honest with you, I wouldn't be surprised
if if you weren't even if you weren't even
voted in legally.
So there Mitt Romney starts walking.
But again, two more things to note.
First, the woman and a guy also there say
you're going to get primaried like a threat.
And Mitt Romney says, of course, that's fine.
That's that's the process.
They're threatening him with something that
he supports being part of the system.
And it's not praise of Mitt Romney's political
views, but he at least has not become so divorced
from just the fundamentals of how politics
works.
He's a that's not really I deserve to be primaried.
That's the system being primary.
That's what we do.
And then the woman throws in.
You weren't even voted in legally.
And that's really scary.
That's scary because it's now completely acceptable
in the magical to offhandedly say about any
elected official that you don't like or who
doesn't support what you want to do in this
case, try to steal the election.
It's now acceptable to say you weren't even
voted in legally.
I've never heard any question about the legality
or integrity of the election in which Mitt
Romney won.
And that's the long term danger that I spoke
about with Sam Seder last night as we were
watching the Georgia Senate results come in,
the normalization and the degradation of our
politics, where with Trump saying it was rigged
and I won, many of his followers fell for
it.
And then now they apply it to any election
of any politician that they don't like.
You weren't even elected legally.
And then lastly, once he got on the plane,
things weren't much better for Mitt Romney.
Trump people starting to chant traitor.
We thank our driver, great, great, great,
great, great, great, great, great, great,
great grandmother.
So, anyway, it must have been a beautiful
fight for a flight, therefore, for Mitt Romney.
So Democrats held the House in 2020.
They won the Senate and won the White House.
But this is going to be a very, very long
two years.
The cultists are going to be with us.
The question is, how engaged will they be?
As I mentioned earlier, and we will be with
you and following it,